okay so thanks for her staying around to
the last talk on the last day and this
was rescheduled from this morning
because I missed a flight from Hong Kong
so I'm gonna be talking about an optimal
algorithm for finding heavy hitters this
is based on a few papers joint work with
Vladimir Braverman Steven chestnut
Nikita if Caen Jelani Nelson and Jang
yu-hwan okay so let me first define the
streaming model for the purposes of this
talk we seem a we see a stream of
elements a1 through a M so M is the
length of the stream and each element is
an integer between 1 and n and for the
purposes of this talk the length of the
stream M is assumed to be polynomially
related to n the elements are presented
in an arbitrary order and algorithms are
given one pass over the data and we'd
like to minute among other things
minimize the many memory usage or the
space complexity in bits for solving a
particular task what we're going to be
looking at our functions of the
frequencies or a number of occurrences
of an item so let F sub J be the number
of occurrences of item J in the stream
our goal is to solve the heavy-hitters
problem which is to find those items J
for which the frequency F sub J is large
and I'll define a few notions of
largeness on the next slide ok so what
does it mean for frequency to be large
one guarantee is the so-called l1
guarantee and here what you'd like to do
is to output a set of items containing
all those items J whose frequency F sub
J is at least 5 times M where Phi is an
input parameter you can think of Phi as
being like 0.1 okay so all items that
occur at least 10% fraction of this
stream
and the set should not contain any item
J whose frequency is at most five minus
epsilon times M where epsilon is also a
parameter you can think of epsilon as
maybe being five over two the reason for
the introduction of epsilon is because
if epsilon is zero then this is actually
a very hard problem
okay finding things that are exactly
above a threshold requires actually
linear space so that's the l1 guarantee
now there's what's called the l2
guarantee which I'll argue is stronger
so here define capital F sub two to be
the sum of squares of the frequencies of
items okay and analogously to the l1
guarantee we would like to output a set
of items containing all those items J
whose squared frequency is at least five
times F two okay those items whose
squared frequency is at least a 10%
fraction of the overall sum of squares
of frequencies and we also don't want to
output any item whose squared frequency
is at most five minus epsilon times F 2
and for those items in between five and
five minus epsilon we can do whatever we
want so I claim the l2 guarantee is much
stronger than the l1 guarantee so in
this talk we're gonna think of Phi and
epsilon as being constants okay fixed
constants independent of of N and here's
an example of a frequency distribution
on items where the first item is an l2
heavy-hitter but it's not an l1
heavy-hitter okay so suppose the first
item has frequency root N and all the
other items have frequency one
then the sum of all the frequencies is
theta n okay you have n items so it's n
plus root n and the first item only
occurs root n times so to find it with
the l1 guarantee I would need to set Phi
to be roughly 1 over root n it's not in
a 1 heavy-hitter for constant Phi
Epsilon on the other hand item 1 is an
l2 heavy-hitter why because if I take
the sum of squares of frequencies this
squared is n each of these squared is 1
I still get theta n as being f2 but the
first item squared frequency is also is
n so it's a constant fraction of the
overall f2 value okay in general an
algorithm that achieves the l2 guarantee
for constant fine epsilon also achieves
the l1 guarantee okay so what is known
about achieving the l2 guarantee which
will be the focus guarantee for this
talk okay what's the first element why
does that achieve the l1 guarantee if
the set will contain
yeah so this this does not satisfy the
l1 guarantee right if I if I want to
sell if I set this fine epsilon to be
constant and I asked you please solve
the l1 guarantee on this vector then you
will not return the first item I see so
maybe I misunderstood what you're saying
I thought you were saying that an l2
algorithm is also another one algorithm
oh I didn't explain why that is
I'm just saying that um yeah I mean so
you do have to test to not output false
positives but I'm just saying for this
vector it will be returned by an l2
algorithm and it won't be returned by no
one algorithm okay
I won't yeah yeah and are there any l2
heavy-hitters also in there that are not
or do l1 heavy hitters they wash out all
the ultimate okay so if I'm at least
five fraction times the sum of the
frequencies then my squared frequency is
at least five squared times the sum of
this times this squared sum of
frequencies the squared sum of
frequencies is at least the sum of
squares of frequencies okay so that
means I'm at least I'm also an l2 heavy
hitter with five squared say yeah so if
I'm male one have you here is that your
question you're asking the converse so
you're saying if I'm in l2 heavy hitter
there would be something to it either
but not an element yes in the presence
of an l1 heavy-hitter there won't be
something that's an O just because yeah
yeah yeah the the single what l1 heavy
hitter sort of dominates the sum of
squares yeah yeah yeah well find that
one yeah okay so let me explain like the
the the previous best algorithm for
solving the l2 guarantee this is due to
Charikar Chen and Frog Colton
so assigned each coordinate or item as
I've been calling it I a random sine
Sigma I okay probably one half one
probably one half minus one and what we
do is we're gonna randomly partition the
items into B buckets okay I've drawn a
picture here and in each bucket we're
gonna maintain a counter okay so what
we're gonna do is we're going to for
each item I've written it as a list of
frequencies each item gets hashed to
some bucket okay so there's a hash
function H and this is the second bucket
and for instance this item number four
goes here so H of 4 equals 2 this is the
set of items that go to this bucket and
what we maintain in that bucket is the
sum over all items there of the
frequency scaled by their sign okay
so this can be maintained in a stream
because if I see a new update to I say
item four I look at which bucket it
hashes - I read it sign and I just added
sign to what's already there okay I
should also mention that these signs
don't need to be truly independent you
don't need a list of n random bits for
these signs they can be generated
pairwise independently so log n bits of
Isis and for this hash function as well
it doesn't need to be truly random
pairwise independence against of Isis so
log n bits for the randomness okay so
what do we do with this data structure
I claim you can estimate the frequency
of any individual item I and I can get
an unbiased estimator so I asked to make
the frequency of item I as follows I
look at the bucket at 1/2 is 2 H of I I
look at the counter in that bucket
C sub H of I and I multiply by its sign
Sigma I okay
I mean it's a lot of items are getting
the same estimator right any items that
go to the same bucket and have the same
sign or estimated the same way so what I
didn't say it has low variance yet I
just said it's an unbiased estimator
okay so why is it unbiased
let's look at the expected value of the
estimator okay and in fact this is just
a kaijus need to take the expectation
over the sine function for any fixing of
H so this is equal to Sigma I so there
should be an expectation everywhere
Sigma I times the sum over all other
items i prime that half to the same
bucket as I of Sigma i prime times
frequency I prime okay okay I didn't
write it the point is though when I take
the expectation of Sigma I times Sigma i
prime if I does not equal I prime this
expectation is actually zero
all right here's pairwise independence
that's all we needed on the other hand
if I equals I prime then Sigma I squared
is 1 and so the expectation of this
quantity is just the the thing
multiplying Sigma I which is f sub I the
frequency of item I okay so I'll explain
in a second what kind of concentration
around the expectation you get but let
me say the algorithm so you're gonna
repeat this basic hashing scheme order
log n times independently okay so you
hash into capital B buckets and think if
capital B is being a constant okay it's
some function of Phi and epsilon these
parameters to the problem that we said
were constant you have to a constant
number of buckets and you repeat that
independently log n times
parallel copies yeah okay so actually in
particularly the space is gonna blow up
by a log n factor okay what you're gonna
do to estimate
I just want to estimate some items
frequency what do I do I look at one of
those parallel copies I look at this
estimator you know it's an estimator of
its frequency I evaluate it and then I
do that for each of the log in copies
and I take the median of all the
estimators and that's my guess for what
the frequency of item is let me just
make a comment on how concentrated this
is around its expectation so okay let me
say this bullet first so the noise in a
bucket meaning so when I compute Sigma I
times the counter in hash bucket I
either generally get F sub I plus
something else okay and that's something
else had expectation zero that's
something else was Sigma of I times the
sum over all items i prime not equal to
I which hash to the same bucket as I of
Sigma i prime times their frequency we
said it's expectation zero but what does
it look like well if I take any vector
any fixed vector and I take the inner
product with a sine vector then what
does that quantity look like
so that that concentrates to the
Euclidean norm of the fixed vector okay
so what does that mean well what is not
now we have to actually use the
randomness in H okay so far all we've
been saying is all this holds for any
for any age well what is the expected
squared Euclidean norm of all the other
junk that goes to the same bucket as a
given item well take the sum of squares
of all frequencies
that's this quantity F 2 we looked at
and I have capital B buckets so I expect
about capital F 2 over B sum of squares
at junk inside that bucket and when I
take the inner product with a sine
vector I get concentration to the square
root of that okay so that's the additive
noise in your estimator for a given one
of these log and repetitions that that's
the additive noise with constant
probability and by repeating this Login
times in parallel and taking the median
I can ensure simultaneously for every
item I that it's frequency is
approximated up to this additive noise
right but with probably nine tenths it's
approximately up to that for one of the
copies and there are only n items so log
in independent trials okay so we said
the number of buckets was constant it's
roughly some function of Phi Epsilon now
what is the space complexity of this
well I have to maintain a counter in
each of these constant number buckets
that's log n bits right I mean it's sum
of sine sum of frequencies it's some
integer between you knows poly and
magnitude log n bits and I repeat the
scheme log n times that gives me log
squared n bits of space
you're saying they don't reduce the
noise in anyone yeah
so let me yeah let me uh emphasize that
because I didn't so far so why do we why
are we doing this but we want to
approximate every single frequency up to
this uniform bound because if we can do
that then we can figure out which ones
are the heavy a heavy hitters and which
ones are not
right so recall we want to find all
those items whose squared frequency is
at least say five times F two right so
if this is the additive error sort of
the squared additive error think of it
as being without the square root it's
roughly F two over B so if B is
something like 1 over Phi then this will
give me everything which is additive
error five times up to okay
we actually want additive error epsilon
F two I don't know if you've been paying
attention to all those details but we
want additive error epsilon F two so we
don't miss classify items but anyway
it's a constant right so B is like 1
over Epsilon yeah so if every item is
approximated up to this additive error
we can figure out which ones are heavy
and which ones are not and that's why
the log and repetitions is needed yeah
oh oh what to think about okay good
no no but actually yeah not entirely
sure what the actual things in some
applications are but yeah no I think of
Phi is being ten percent or something
I mean and it's huge actually so one
thing one application of this is for
monitoring traffic on the network and
you can think of n as being sort of the
active IP addresses on some particular
network right so suppose one thing maybe
maybe one thing you want to know is like
which which side is receiving the most
packets and given in any given amount of
time and n would would correspond you
know it could actually correspond to all
possible IP addresses or maybe there's
some hashing that you do on before this
but n could be very large I mean it
could be I don't know
larger it really depends on the
application but maybe at least like 10
to the 7 10 to the 8th I don't know yeah
actually no why not even larger I mean
10 I'm not sure like yeah yeah smaller
Phi is harder right so like yeah yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah we actually
do have near the optimal depends on Phi
to I'm just gonna suppress that talk ok
so this was the previous best algorithm
it Chiefs log squared n bits of space
and it turns out that if you allow
deletions in the stream then this log
squared is actually optimal in work we
showed with the ball at all
so deletions means you know in it's some
point in the stream I can say please
remove one occurrence of I and you know
the this data structure is really easy
to maintain in the presence of deletions
right if I want to remove one occurrence
of item four I go to its bucket and
instead of adding the sign I subtract
its sign and log squared is the tight
space bound in that case but what about
insertion only streams okay and this was
the model in this paper by Ilan Matias
and Sega T which really sort of revived
data streams in theoretical computer
science it has applications in search
logs network traffic databases
scientific data the only known lower
bound is log n bits okay and this just
follows sort of trivial a to report the
identity of the heavy hitter of a heavy
hitter
okay so this is quadratic gap and that's
our contribution of closing this gap we
give an algorithm using log n log log
and bits of space and recently we
actually removed the log log n so we got
log n bits of space I'll mention that
briefly the improve the log log and
removal the same techniques that we use
here give a number of other results in
data streams one thing you might want to
do is estimate this quantity AB to
itself the sum of squares of frequencies
this is known as the self-join size in
databases it's also the collision
probability of a distribution so it has
its own I mean the second moment is of
course important right so so what we can
do is we can estimate it at every single
point in the stream okay so at every
single point I tell you a constant
factor multiplicative approximation to F
2 why is that interesting because it's
known that at any given time if I want
to estimate F 2 with error probability
Delta that I need log n times log 1 over
Delta bits of space ok log n log 1 over
Delta with error probably Delta at any
given time so the natural thing to do
would be said to set Delta to be 1 over
the length of the stream which is poly n
in this case and that would give you log
squared n bits of space for solving this
problem and so we somehow beat that
Union bound ok and intuitively we're
beating the Union bound because you know
f2 is not arbitrary at all points in the
stream it's very related at one time to
the next time ok yes it improves this
Union bound another problem that people
look at in practice is just computing
the maximum frequency of a data set okay
and sort of immediately from our result
we can compute the maximum frequency up
to an additive square root epsilon F 2
the reason this is immediate is because
we just find the heavy hitters and
approximate frequencies for those heavy
hitters and we just output the frequency
of the
the largest approximate frequency and
that's our approximation to the largest
frequency okay I'm not gonna focus on
this problem so in the rest of the talk
I'm gonna focus on this algorithm that
gets the heavy hitters algorithm yeah
this was a question in the iit kanpur
data stream list okay so first to get
some intuition for the problem a yeah so
okay so this is just the statement of
the problem we're assuming Phi is
constant since Phi is constant how many
items I can have squared frequency at
least five times F 2 okay so at most you
know 10 items can be 10 percent of F 2
so at most order 1 over Phi which is a
constant for us so suppose at the
beginning of the algorithm I just take
all my n items and I have them into a
constant number of buckets ok so I just
take my n items and I have some of them
here some of them here constant number
of times and then I run a heavy-hitters
algorithm on each of these parts of this
partition ok
so with good probability all items I
whose squared frequencies at least 5
times F 2 will go to their own bucket
they'll be isolated okay so we just
conditioned on that event and the
problem you know the space just blows up
by a constant and the problem reduces to
just having a single item I star which
is again between 1 and n whose frequency
is at least square root Phi F 2 and
we're trying to output the value I star
the identity of I story okay so yeah to
get some intuition for this problem
let's make two assumptions that are not
quite realistic we're going to assume
that all frequencies of items other than
I star are
zero or one okay just just to start
and moreover even under that assumption
we're going to assume the frequency by
star is at least root n log n ok so note
that if all these frequencies are 0 1
the sum of squared frequencies is at
most n so being a legitimate l2
heavy-hitter just means I need to be at
least root n but I'm assuming something
stronger that it's root n log n ok and
for the moment let's also not count the
space to store random hash functions ok
so we have some huge random tape that
we'll deal with later so the intuition
is as follows just like in count sketch
we're going to start by assigning each
item I a random sign Sigma
and we're gonna randomly partition the
items now into only two buckets
and just like in count sketch we're
gonna maintain a signed counter in each
bucket so c1 is the sum over all items I
which hash to bucket one H of I equals 1
that's Sigma I times F of sub i n c2 is
the sum over all items I that hash to
the second bucket of Sigma I times F
times I same thing as counts cache and
let's suppose that this heavy-hitter I
star hashes to the first bucket just to
see what's happening then what do the
values c1 and c2 look like as the stream
evolves this is my question so what what
do these things look like
as you see more and more updates
yeah that's that's the quantitative
bound I mean they look like unbiased
random walks okay right so let's just
write these in a little bit of a
different way so we said I star goes to
the first bucket
so let's write C 1 equals Sigma I star
fi star plus the sum of all the other
items I not equal I star you know of
their contribution to C 1 and that's
right C 2 in the same way we had on the
previous slide then the claim is that C
1 minus the sine of I star times fi star
and C 2 they just evolved as unbiased
random walks okay so here we're using
our assumption that all the other
frequencies were 0 or 1 so we just see
an item once or no times and we're not
counting the space to store the
randomness so all the signs are
independent you know so when you see a
new item we just see a plus 1 or minus 1
with equal probability okay and what do
we know about random walks if someone in
the audience said we know there's a
positive constant C so that with
constant probability simultaneously at
all times in the random walk the
deviations from the origin the magnitude
of the random walk is at most C root n
okay I think this is called Levy's
theorem but but it's a senator Thurmond
random walks so okay so there's an event
that you condition on and once you
condition on that these counters will
see 1 minus Sigma I star fi star and C 2
are always bounded by C root n
so this should suggest an algorithm to
figure out which bucket contains I star
okay yeah so here's the algorithm
eventually you see at least to see route
and updates to itemized star okay so no
matter what sign you assigned I star by
triangle inequality
it means the counter that contains isar
is going to be at least larger than C
root n because the other stuff is at
most C root n if this event occurs but
then you know which bucket contains I
star so you sort of learned one bit of
information about I star right you have
to randomly into two buckets you learn a
bit of information okay so one thing we
could do to recover AI star is to repeat
this login times in parallel if we did
this we'd recover something very similar
to the counts catch data structure right
this would give us log squared n bits of
space we don't want blocks for n bits of
space we want close to login bits of
space so what we can try to do instead
is to repeat this login times
sequentially okay
so repeating sequentially yes so the
algorithm is is natural you wait until
one of the two counters in magnitude
exceeds C root n if it's the first
counter then you say that ice you say a
Q PI star equals one otherwise you say a
key VARs Ice R equals two this gives one
bit of information about I star and now
you repeat you just start completely
over initialize two new counters to 0
and perform the procedure again ok you
can show yeah no new hash functions yeah
yeah so I'm not keeping track of the
randomness but that's actually a good
point because you actually sort of have
to keep track of that hash function to
sort of recover I star at the end
but let's ignore that for now yeah you
can actually do an demise this part with
Nissan pseudo-random generator but I'll
get if I have time here which is kind of
like a multi-level yeah so if you assume
that the frequency by star is at least
root n log n it takes about route and
updates for this to happen once and you
can show that with very good probability
you will have at least say 10 log n
repetitions for appropriate constants of
this of this hash the two bucket process
and you can show that most of them are
going to succeed okay sometimes this
event doesn't hold for this random walk
and by turn off balance no these are
actually independent I mean what you can
show is that there's only going to be a
single value of I star whose hash values
match a 2/3 fraction of the larger side
okay so I do this I see which one is
larger I do it again I see which one is
larger and by turn off bounds I star
will be the unique item which matches
the larger one on at least a 2/3
fraction and now I have I star or at
least now I have all the hash functions
which described by star ignoring
randomness I have I star okay so yeah by
the way so my talk was rescheduled to
four and the previous speaker was for
half an hour but I I don't know how long
I can go people leave ok yeah so it's
the last talk nothing okay yeah so okay
we don't actually have these two
assumptions of course right that the
frequencies are binary and this heavy
thing is super heavy root n log n
instead of just ruin and we're gonna fix
both of these using the theory of
Gaussian processes okay so let me say
what those are so a Gaussian process is
just the collection of random variables
X sub little T in some capital T is the
index set of the random variables and
the only property that you have is that
every linear combination of the random
variables is Gaussian in this case we're
only going to be looking at finite
collections of random variables so this
word finite doesn't need to be here
basically it's a collection of random
variables so that any linear combination
of these random variables is Gaussian
okay for us we can so in particular each
one of these is Gaussian though we don't
have independence for us it's enough to
assume the expectation of all the
gaussians of all the X keys is 0 ok that
that's all from the theory that we're
gonna need and you can show in this case
when the expectations are all zeroes the
process is entirely determined by the
covariances ok the expected value of X s
times XT if I tell you all pairs s and T
I tell you this value and this is
related to a fact that a Gaussian
distribution is determined by its mean
and covariance okay so for this Gaussian
process we can define a distance
function on these indices so the
distance between indices s and T is
defined to be the square root of the
expected value of X s minus XT squared
ok
this distance function is actually a
metric it satisfies triangle inequality
it's actually not quite a metric it's a
pseudo metric because in general this
can be zero when X does not equal T but
we don't care about that we just care
that it satisfies the triangle
inequality
okay so why do we care at all about
Gaussian processes what is the
connection to data streams so supposed
to replace the sine Sigma I that we've
been talking about in these counters
like we maintain like Sigma I F I
suppose we replace them with Gaussian
random variables G of I and let's
consider sort of just a generic counter
see at time T time means I've seen T
updates in the stream then C of T is
defined to be the sum over items I of
the Gaussian associated with item I G of
I times the frequency of item I after
seeing the first T updates in the stream
okay I'm just summing over all items
this is just what a counter might look
like replacing the signs with gaussians
yeah so fi T is frequency after t at t
insertions so the claim is that actually
C of T is a Gaussian process
yeah so okay yeah so this infinite
random tape is getting abused right so
actually at the end of the day the
gaussians can be replaced with sines
I just wanted to state it this way for
the connection the Gaussian processes
and also at the end of the day actually
for Y's independence suffice is for the
gal seems but you know let's let's
ignore that for now yeah so see if T is
actually a Gaussian process do you guys
see why this is true
right suppose I take some finite linear
combinations like C of time 1 C of time
to see of time 3 I add them up when I
add them up I can group the the sum I
can add up the sums that course that
those terms that correspond to the same
GI and then I have a sum of independent
G is I mean in the ideal case all the
gi's are independent and the sum of
independent gaussians is gaussian right
so ok so it's a Gaussian process
okay still why do we care so we're going
to use actually a very powerful theorem
called the chaining inequality which
turns out actually surprisingly to me to
be sort of exactly what we need here so
that the chaining inequality originally
approved by ferny cand but sort of
stated in different language by telegram
is the following so let X sub t be a
Gaussian process and let's we're free to
choose any nested sequence of subsets of
our index set T okay t0 contained in t1
and t2 etc so that the first set t0 has
size 1 and the I'd set TI has size at
most 2 to the 2 to the I then what the
chaining inequality says is the expected
value of the maximum absolute value of
XT okay for all of our random variables
XT the expected maximum value is up to a
constant factor the maximum over indices
T of a weighted sum this weighted sum is
the distance of index T to the ID set
times 2 to the I over 2 summed over all
I
yeah yeah let me say what that is this
is the natural notion of distance were
we saw what the distance between two
indices was right it's the square root
of the expected value of between index X
s and index T of X s minus XT squared
that was our distance function
associated to this and the distance
between an index T and a set is the the
minimum over all indices s in the set of
the distance between T and s
okay so this might be a little bit and
serious but it'll be maybe hopefully
it'll be clear in a second so we set our
counter C of T a generic counter that we
might want to maintain in the stream is
a Gaussian process so what what is this
thing upper bounding it if we apply it
to the counter it's telling you the
maximum at any time in the stream of the
counter value well that's exactly what
we wanted from this random walk theory
right the random walks were telling us
at any time you never deviate by more
than root n or C root n this is the same
kind of upper bound that random walk
theory was giving us before now we don't
have any assumptions on frequencies
being 0 or 1 okay so let me just say
okay so how can we apply this to this
counter
so I'm now going to give you a nested
sequence of subsets
okay I'm gonna choose them in a way
which makes this right-hand side to be
something small that I want okay so let
F 2 of T be the value of F 2 remember
the sum of squares of frequencies after
you see t stream updates and the idea
which I'll show pictorially on the next
slide is to let the TI be a recursive
partitioning of the stream where f 2 of
T changes roughly by a factor of 2 okay
so I'm going to show this on the next
slide but I just want to mention that
yeah these sets are gonna be
corresponding to x in the stream at
which F 2 changes by a certain value and
note that this this is not algorithmic
right I I get a specified whatever this
is and this is just going to be a tool
in the analysis okay right like the
expected maximum of this thing I get to
choose whatever I want for my for my
nested sequence of subsets okay so here
it is pictorially so here's my stream
and I'm gonna define a sub little T to
be the first point in the stream for
which the f2 value exceeds half of the
overall f2 value meaning the f2 at the
end of the stream / - there is some
unique point when I go through the items
in the stream at which the f2 value
first exceeds this
and I'm going to set my first set in my
nested sequence of subsets to be that
index T in general what I'm gonna do is
let capital T sub I be the set of 2 to
the 2 to the I times positions in the
stream T 1 T 2 T to the to the I such
that TJ is the first time in the stream
for which the F 2 value at time T J
exceeds the overall F 2 value times J
over 2 to the 2 to the I okay I get to
choose to the through the I points and I
evenly spread the F 2 value across them
so the conditions we need for applying
the changing inequality hold we do have
a nested sequence of subsets
okay these points you know as I
increases this is a nested sequence of
subsets the first set has size 1 and by
construction the Isetta size at most to
the 2 to the I okay so let's apply the
training inequality and see what comes
out of it
so I've just repeated the statement of
the chaining inequality on top here yeah
okay so here's the distance function
that Rocco asked about we need to
evaluate this distance for our
particular Gaussian process which is
these counters and for this nested
sequence of subsets I just told you so
the distance between T and set T sub I
is the minimum over all times
TJ in T sub I of the distance between T
and TJ okay which is the square root of
the expected value now what is our
random variable at time T it's this
counter C of T and what is our random
variable at time T J it's this counter
TC of TJ so it's the expected value of
the squared difference
okay but what is what is C of T minus C
of T J
so we call C of T is a counter right
like see if T is is yeah it's like you
know the frequency is up to time T times
the Gaussian associated with item I all
right this is C of T and what is c ftj
it just replaces t with TJ and what is
the difference well the difference is
exactly the sum with the G is but this
is replaced with the difference of the
frequencies between the two times okay
now if I take the expected value squared
of the differences between two times I
get the f2 value between those two times
but we defined these sets to evenly
partition the f2 value across across the
the stream so there's there's always I
mean so if I look at time T I there's
always a point TJ and TI for which they
have to value between those two points
is at most F 2 over 2 to the 2 to the I
okay I mean that's how we defined this
even partitioning the partition links
are leaving yeah TJ is the first point
in the stream for which the f2 value at
time T J is at least J times f2 of M
over 2 to the 2 to the I oh yeah sorry
so Ti is the set of these items sorry
yeah this no no yeah this is bad grammar
TI is the set of these items now what
are these items
TJ which is one item here just for some
arbitrary J is the time in the stream
for which the f2 value at time T J is at
least sort of a J over 2 to the to the I
fraction of the overall f2 value
okay yeah okay so you can actually show
the since everything is increasing the
these have two values in between these
blocks they sum up to at most epic
they're actually individually at most f2
over 2 to the to the I which I think was
your question so this this value there's
a TJ I can make this at most
f2 over 2 to the to the okay so let's
just plug this into the training
inequality this says that the expected
maximum value of the counter at any time
is up to a constant factor the max over
all times of this weighted sum this
weighted sum is the sum over all I of to
2i over 2 times this distance this
distance we just said is at most
f2 over 2 to the 2 to the I square root
so that's that that that decays faster
than geometric that that's order square
root of 2 we didn't actually need the
full power the chaining actually
anything that made this geometric would
have been enough for us yeah so oh so
just replacing gaussians with plus/minus
ones actually the chaining inequality
holds yeah so you can show that like the
expected supremum with plus/minus ones
and that for gaussians the the 1/4 plus
minus ones is upper bounded by the 1/4
gaussians up to a constant factor okay
so this is called comparison theorem I
think so this has the same behavior as
for random walks right because it says
you know in our random walk example this
order square root of f2 would have been
square root of n and this is saying at
no time do we deviate more from the
origin than Square
but this is a much more general
statement in terms of f2 okay okay okay
so yeah we have some assumptions that we
wanted to remove with this earlier
intuition the one was that all the
frequencies were binary and one is that
even if they are this heavy guy is rude
and login and what we just showed this
Gaussian process this chaining
inequality theory it removes the
restriction that the frequencies are
binary nowhere did we use that in the
argument okay
yeah so just to reiterate the random
walk bound of seaweed and holds without
this restriction in that earlier example
but we sort of still need fi star to be
at least sorry this should be route up
to Roo depth to login and why was that
because we said okay well we're gonna
wait a little bit until one of these
counters exceeds C root up 2 or C root n
in the earlier example and when it does
we learn one bit of information about I
star and then we repeat we do it again
that's kind of why we needed log in this
log in here because we needed it to be
sufficiently frequent so that it we
could do this thing log n times to get
log in bits of information about the
heavy-hitter but you know ideally we'd
like to just replace this restriction
with F of I star is at least square root
Phi F 2 you know the legitimate
heavy-hitter okay so I'm gonna ignore
log log n factors for this talk I'll
just give us a simple way of achieving
this and what we can do is we can assume
that fi star is at least log log n times
square root of F 2 okay I can assume fi
star is at least log log n times square
root of F 2 why is that well we said in
the beginning we can have to a number of
buckets and run our algorithm on each
bucket okay when our heavy hitters
algorithm on each of the buckets
independently so instead of hashing to a
constant number of buckets at the
beginning of the stream suppose I happen
to log log n buckets that'll blow up my
space by a log log n factor but it'll
make my thing even at my true
heavy-hitter even heavier okay because
what's left in the bucket is only likely
to be a 1 over log log and fraction of
the overall sum of squared frequencies
okay so this is a way of making your
item sort of artificially larger well we
could have to log in buckets then we
would use too much space but let's let's
hash the log log in buckets okay
so now this is the final technical slide
on the algorithm okay so we know our
item is is squared frequency is log log
n times the sum of the squares of all
the other frequencies let's do the
following procedure which we call
amplification we're going to create log
log n pairs of streams from the input
stream okay so we have our input stream
and we're going to create a left stream
and a right stream what that means and
we're going to do that that's going to
partition the stream we're going to
partition the stream into two pieces
some items go to a left stream and the
remaining items go to a right stream and
we're going to do that again and again
and we're gonna do that log log n times
independently so just to formally state
what this is for each J in your log log
and repetitions of this process you
choose a hash function H sub J which
Maps the items 1 through n to either the
left call it 0 or the right call it 1
and the Jade stream the left part is the
original stream restricted to items I
which hash to 0
from items yeah it's not based on I mean
all the updates are like plus one or
something yeah I mean it's based on the
item identifier so half of that
I mean roughly so some fraction of the
items go to the left and some go to the
right defined by this hash function yes
so yeah the ones that go to the left say
the hash function evaluated on the ID is
zero and to the right is the remaining
items the hash to one okay now we're
gonna maintain a counter for the left
stream and for the right stream yeah I'm
sort of overtime so if you want to leave
go ahead so the main ideas have been
presented but I'm just gonna finish this
since we're almost done yeah so we have
a left stream and a right stream and
we're gonna maintain a counter for the
left stream and a counter for the right
stream and the counter is just the inner
product with gaussians and the
frequencies of the items that go to the
left stream and the counter on the right
is just the inner product of gaussians
and the frequencies with the items that
go to the right stream these generic
counters that we've been looking at so
by applying this chaining inequality and
the turn off bound okay just let me just
say something the I star is going to go
either to the left or the right stream
and the site that it goes to is likely
to be much larger than the other side
why because all of these things there
are about route F to an expectation at
all times by this chaining inequality
but we said I start with log log n times
larger than square root of f 2 so it's
much larger it's like log log n times
the noise and everything that's left now
that square root of f 2 though that
bound was only an expectation for the
noisy stuff but we have log log and
repetitions of this and so by Markov
bound all of the all of these things
will be at most square root of F 2 times
log log n on all repetitions for the
left and the right these counter values
by the chaining inequality and the
markov bound will be at most square root
of F 2 log log n but I star is larger
than square root of F 2 log log n so
what's going to happen after I see
enough updates in the stream the larger
counter is going to be the one that
contains I star
okay and I'm doing this log log n times
independently and the larger counter
stays larger forever by the chaining
inequality right at all times this is at
most rude f2 logo again the remaining
stuff so after I see enough updates of
my heavy item then it's always going to
be larger than the remaining stuff and
so that the larger counter stays larger
forever okay so the larger counter is
the one that contains I star now what
was the point of this well the point of
this is suppose we just run our
algorithm of learning one bit of ice
star and then learning another bit of
ice star like half into two buckets
learn a bit of AI star hash into two
buckets learn a bit of AI star but we
only run it on the items that correspond
to being in the bucket which has the
larger counter on all log log n
repetitions right so we have two
counters for the first repetition two
counters for the next one two counters
to the next one after I see enough
updates this counter is always going to
be larger then this counter is always
gonna be larger this sucker is always
gonna be larger and now I'm just gonna
run this process of learning one bit of
ice star only on the items that have to
the larger counter in all log log and
repetitions okay so I'm basically
sieving like I'm filtering out the
stream I'm only looking at those items
which go to the larger counter in all
the repetitions I star goes there so we
still have our heavy-hitter and the
expected amount of other stuff that goes
there that's the point
like the f2 value of all the other stuff
that agrees with all the larger counters
well it's going to be roughly f2 over
poly log n right like what's the
fraction of items that agrees in all log
log on repetitions 1 over 2 to the log
log n that's roughly 1 over log n I can
make that 1 over log squared n if I want
but and they're expected f2 values F 2
over poly log n well that's great
because I star goes there and now all
these items that also go there got even
smaller
so now I'm like super heavy I'm not just
log log n times what's left
I'm poly log n times what's left that
makes sense so this is why we call it
amplification but if I'm poly log in
times what's left and I just have what I
had before right I learned one bit
then I learn another bit and I can
repeat that log n times because I'm so
much heavier than what's left so so
that's that's the sequential repetition
thing yeah so there is like something
here which is those are the larger of
the two counters it is changing early in
the stream like which counter is larger
like it's changing and whenever it
changes I do have to restart my whole
procedure of learning one bit of I star
but after I see enough updates it never
changes the larger one stays larger
forever yeah
sorry yeah so you're doing this and
every time the larger counter changes
you restart this learn one bit at a time
procedure but you know after enough
times in this after long enough time in
the stream the the larger counter stays
large larger forever and and you have
enough updates at that point to actually
learn I star okay so is it clear or as
clear as can be and okay so that that's
sort of the amplification yeah so this
is really out of time the randomization
we have to account for the randomness in
our algorithm there are two things we
need to do randomize the Gaussian
process we need to do an demise the hash
functions that were used to learn a bit
of information we achieve one let me
just say some keywords without any
details by using the randomize
johnson-luna Strasse theorem so roughly
speaking we take these this inner
product of gaussians with these
frequencies we first take this n
dimensional frequency vector and we
squash it down to a log n dimensional
frequency vector using dots and linen
straws and that preserves all the
pairwise
distances expected value fi minus FJ
squared that that's sort of what dancin
Dennis Ross does and if you do that
there's this thing called sleppy Anne's
lemma which says if you preserve the
distance function at all pairs by a
constant then you also the Gaussian
process is roughly preserved so the
supremum is preserved to is using a more
standard technique called Nisan
pseudo-random generator and streaming
pioneered by Indyk and let me just
mention that we recently removed the log
log N and got log n bits and there were
multiple sources where the log log n was
coming from one was this amplification
that I just discussed and here we use a
key observation which is that as you're
doing this filtering of items the heavy
item is becoming even heavier as you go
so if I if I instead of having log log n
if I only have like a constant number
then my item is I feel throughout the
constant fraction my item is already
becoming a little bit heavier and this
allows you to sort of bootstrap and save
that log log n another thing is with the
demand amuse ation we show for wise
independence is enough to deer an demise
our particular Gaussian process and just
to conclude so we beat count sketch for
l2 heavy-hitters we get log n bits
ultimately instead of log squared n bits
and some new results for estimating app
two at all times in a stream and maximum
frequency estimation a lot of questions
here so so count sketch is used in
practice for things like network
monitoring that I said and we have a
preliminary implementation and it's not
clear yet if it's a significant
practical improvement but we're trying
to make it one and and sort of like
Gaussian processes are new to data
streams and so maybe they're helpful for
solving other problems more generally so
so that's all thanks
Russians
there's a Gaussian constant so can you
do this for norms moments other than the
second moment is zero to two like oh oh
the index table stuff yes I think they
have to they'll to guarantee what so it
actually implies the l1 guarantee for
constant Phi Epsilon and so I think it
implies the LP guarantee for constant
Phi Epsilon for any P between zero and
two the issue though is for P larger
than two you actually can't achieve poly
logarithmic space it's known that you
need polynomial in n like n to the Omega
one space yeah the intuition for that
yeah so yeah yeah it's a good question
so this is a communication complexity
based proof the intuition is sort of
like the concentration that you get in
l2 is sort of the the best kind of
concentration you can get for random
variables I mean this is sort of the int
the I mean sort of the heart instance is
yeah if you have a frequency which is
like n to the one third and all the
frequencies are one you'd want to find
this with l3 heavy-hitters and sort of
you can take linear combinations of your
frequencies but sort of the standard
deviation for whatever I mean you're
gonna choose some random variables here
and for sort of many classes of random
variables this is going to concentrate
to roughly root plus or minus root n
which is going to be larger than this
and there's sort of no family of random
variables that really helps you to find
this item that's some intuition as to
why this upper bound would fail yeah I
don't know if that helps or I can
explain the the lower bound proof if
you're interested maybe after that yeah
any other questions
okay so thanks